we are taking your calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0
47 50 and there are so many folks
interested in getting on let's go to our
caller from the four one four area code
who's calling today from four one four
hi David hi who's Dan this is anpan and
I have a question about kind of what
you've been saying for months about the
only way to get Trump out is by voting
impeachment not being the way to go 25th
amendment not being the way to go and
seeing Trump's increasing incompetence
in just today's news with Trump ring
gauging with conflict in Iran this
obviously being an incredibly dangerous
situation
yes um especially layered on top of the
coronavirus this is coupled with the
voter suppression being in wisconsin you
know we had that whole battle with you
know our elections still going on in the
midst of a pandemic voter suppression
etc it seems like the call for the only
way to get him out is by voting is
becoming a weaker and weaker argument
because Republicans keep attacking that
Avenue to get him out do you have
anything to say to that argument of
course and my argument is not that Trump
is not worthy of impeachment and removal
but with the Republican Senate it will
not happen it will not happen
I'm not saying Donald Trump is not
worthy of removal under the 25th
amendment
but he isn't his own cabinet is not
going to move to remove Donald Trump so
when I say the only way of getting him
out is voting him out I'm not pretending
that the election will necessarily be
fair and I'm not pretending that
impeachment and the 25th amendment would
be incorrect strategies I
merely saying the only chance we
actually have is to vote him out in
November and so they're gonna be purging
the voter rolls they've already been
doing it they're going to be limiting
early voting they're going to try to
push for in-person voting even if it's
dangerous because of the pandemic which
is disproportionately likely to keep
Democratic voters at home we need to
knowing that bla be every state to go to
vote by mail at least the states that
will matter here in Massachusetts
there's already three or forty mayors
that have written to the governor saying
we have the system we have absentee
ballots let's expand it now
Massachusetts won't make a difference in
the election if Wisconsin and Michigan
and these other states do it so we need
to knowing that it's our only shot
knowing they won't play fair we need to
get moving now to ensure that we're
actually positioning to remove him in
November well a free with that we're
saying that our efforts should be in
things like reaching out to lawmakers to
say let's get this boat by mail thing
rolling yes that's whatever you can have
at least a fair shot that's right and
we've got one right there every
opportunity we have to fight the voter
roll purges as well exactly well I
appreciate your time I appreciate you
like this is that a concern of mine
because I feel I've been feeling more
and more frustrated with your increasing
call for you know voters vote the way is
the only way to get out him out and it's
like well they keep attacking that
Avenue but at least you know it I feel a
little bit of hope there's something we
can do about that
right for example when Wisconsin had
their primary you know I was sending an
email black you know I had 11th hour
email blast to I think it was the health
secretary to you know put in some
emergency measure I mean it was going
out on a limb entirely but at least I
felt like I could do something so
hopefully now that we have a lot more
time we can try to mitigate this kind of
you know this attempt that you know
completely squashing democracy yes and
we've got to get active
now which is why it's so important and
that you are talking about it thank you
so much for the call I really do
appreciate hearing from you